[Music]
[Music]
hey
here we are again it's sunday hey oracle
man you
same thing happened with beige did her
blood work a couple days ago
[ __ ] her kidneys shot liver liver i
mean yeah
uh they're doing a they gave us some uh
medicine that's making her feel a lot
better yeah she's acting normal
yeah she's 13. we don't know what
happened but her liver was like real
small
i don't know if you should be born like
that or
if if it was some kind of disease she
got from eating lizards
but uh they got her on some pills
and she's feeling a little bit better
we're just gonna see i'll know more next
month that's why i really didn't say
much about it
yeah but um she's 13 so
we'll see yeah i mean
they can live longer than that but
that's not a young cat
you know yeah well we'll see for liver
transplant no i know that's a shame
but it's like you know hopefully the
medication seems to be like doing her
really
good and she's acting normal bringing
the babies around the house again
yeah cause she wasn't doing that for a
few days yeah and she doesn't growl at
you when you try to touch her
yeah she's acting pretty normal actually
but we'll see
like i said she's got to go back again
this is the you know end of the month
right yeah
january yeah and we'll see all right so
we're talking about uh
the new season of cobra kai we're not
going to three i'm not going to spoil it
i'm not going to spoil it because it
only just
i feel like the camera is you look like
you're way over there we go
all right you were like going off the
edge like yeah
there we go i liked the first uh you
know i liked cobra kai
i thought the first two two seasons were
really good third season's good
it's soapy but it's supposed to be i
really kind of wanna the thing that i
love about cobra kai
is that this is a really hard tone to
get right because
it's kind of like it's gonna be
cheesy because the original movies are
cheesy but it's it leans into the
cheesiness
and it also does it in a way that's like
really charming
and like really endearing you know what
i mean it's winking at you the whole
time like but it's not like making fun
it's like affectionate it's like
affectionately cheesy
you know what i mean it's like it got
that tone like exactly right
yeah all the old guys are they do [ __ ]
like get into car chases and then
they'll play old [ __ ] you know
motley crew music and [ __ ] from the 80s
and
just a bunch of 80s call backs and
making jokes about [ __ ] karate like
karate i thought that went out in the
80s you know it's just
yeah it's very it's very self-aware but
like i said it's still
really it actually had really like heart
you know really like kind of
heartwarming moments and [ __ ] like that
and um i think my favorite thing about
this i don't know if you guys have seen
because the first two seasons
um if you didn't know we're actually on
youtube red and we
um we got youtube red specifically for
that that was like the only reason that
we got it was because we wanted to watch
the first two seasons of cobra kai
and then netflix very happily picked up
the first two seasons and uh they were
the ones that funded the third season so
now all three seasons are on
netflix and you can watch all them so i
don't know if like some people just like
you know watch it on youtube and it's
like are trying to catch up or whatever
so like i said i don't want to like
spoil too much even from like the first
two seasons because
in case like you didn't have youtube red
and you didn't see it and now you're
trying to like watch all three seasons
on netflix um
you know i don't want to like spoil too
much about it but i think
uh as in the previous seasons my
favorite thing
about this is the johnny lawrence
character
william zabka yeah it is so [ __ ]
funny that they basically made him like
it sounds it's not like super believable
but they
kind of made it almost like he was in a
coma for like 30 years he was like so
stuck in the 80s
he doesn't know like how laptop works he
doesn't like
know how to get on the internet he
doesn't know how to do facebook
it's like every time he's you know
telling his kids like to do something
it's like
hey do one of those hash brown things
you know like hash brown whatever the
[ __ ] instead of hashtag
and it's like so [ __ ] funny he didn't
know
he didn't know that what was on his cell
phone could you could also access
facebook he didn't realize that facebook
was on your laptop yeah he's like yeah
i lost my phone or whatever and miguel's
kind of like
um you know you can get that on your
laptop too right
like you didn't really seem to realize
but it's like i
i love that it's like like i said it's
super not believable like that somebody
would be that out of it
but i don't know but it still like works
i guess because
it's just like such a funny like running
gag like through the whole show that he
doesn't know
i mean that hash brown thing that just
like makes me laugh every single [ __ ]
time he said well
he was he was kind of he was kind of a
fossil remember he was living in that
old [ __ ] bombed out apartment yeah
yeah
and uh so he worked kind of a menial job
so
it might be yeah i mean it's not it's
i'm sure it could happen like if you're
not really interested in like he's got
to use a phone but he didn't really
know how to use the internet which
that's kind of weird my dad doesn't know
how to use the internet but he's in his
70s right
yeah i mean but
he's still like driving around like an
old [ __ ] yeah and these guys 80s
muscle cars these guys are only supposed
to be a couple years older than me i
think they're all supposed to be like
maybe five years older than me yeah
maybe not even they might be like the
same age they should be the same yeah
or maybe it's just a little bit older
yeah i'm not really sure i can't really
imagine it
but yeah so this this season like i said
now if you saw the end of season two
like the big brawl and the big thing
that happened to miguel
um this is basically season three has
like a whole bunch of
plot you know uh plot threads that kind
of stemmed from
that um happening so you have
um all the [ __ ] happening with miguel
like you know is he gonna be okay
what happened back in vietnam what well
yeah we'll get into that too
like uh robbie taking off uh and kind of
going on the lamb
you have so you have that going on
there's some [ __ ] with um
because the big brawl um
because it was all like karate centered
so now like the town has kind of turned
against karate
so that's kind of like a moral panic
like about karate now so
daniel's car dealership is suffering
because nobody wants to go there anymore
so he's having problems with that um i
will spoil the fact that he goes to
okinawa
in this season which i actually kind of
like that um
and there are some faces from the
original movies
yeah holy crap dude i feel like they got
everybody from the original pretty much
other than the ones that are dead and
sadly but
um even what like little tiny parts and
stuff like that it's like they got
[ __ ]
everybody back for this [ __ ] and i was
just kind of like that's pretty awesome
and if you remember part two when he
goes to okinawa that was part two i
think when
yeah yeah wait was that the second one
or the fingers part two i can't remember
it we just watched all of them like not
too long ago i think it's part two
when he goes to okinawa it's [ __ ]
they did this [ __ ] back in the 70s
back in the 80s and like i've said
before on other shows man
our conception of the [ __ ] east was
very [ __ ] different back then yeah we
were talking about that on our gremlins
like when he goes to go okinawa it's
still the 1700s in okinawa
tiny village like [ __ ] from another
era with people and [ __ ] kimonos and
[ __ ] you know what i mean
they weren't wearing that in the [ __ ]
nature it was the eight like it was like
a big city it was just kind of like
funny so and they they kind of they kind
of play on that a little bit yeah they
they uh lampshade that a little bit so i
think that's like pretty funny that they
kind of yeah it's just like mug wise
coming from china because it's china of
course they got magical [ __ ] monsters
in china
although i will tell you the trouble in
little china is a good illustration of
what people
yeah actually that was yeah i was
thinking about what it was really like
but it wasn't just the east because i
remember in the 90s
like my stepdad's mother when i was
in the uk like living in the uk or going
back and forth to the uk she asked me if
they had
vcrs over there in the 90s
yeah weird and early 2000s and
i'm like it's not it wasn't just us i
mean
what i'm like yeah they got electricity
and indoor toilets too
there are there are there are people
like in china that and in japan that
think that america is nothing but just
people doing
doing square dancing dressed up as
[ __ ] cowboys and it used to be that
way
you know and so it went both ways
that's what we thought would be really
funny it's just like that they did
they did they had there was all the
japanese had a whole bunch of
stereotypes about americans
i mean i guess everybody has stereotypes
about you know countries you've never
been to
because you only see like a really
limited um
you know interpretation of it you know
what i mean
yeah so it's like i i feel like people
still think that
i mean particularly in the 80s too they
thought the entire continent of africa
was just people in like tribes and stuff
like no they have like actual cities
like big cities and everything and it's
just
like it's like the continent is those
[ __ ] messiahs
right it's like that's a pretty small
like you know what i mean
so i kind of feel so i like that they
kind of um address that like in this
series like when he goes back there
and last night i'll tell you what man
[ __ ] i don't know if you guys had fun
on the show we we did
we got loaded last night we did yeah i'm
not even sure how the show
ended i think i'm never sure how the
show happened it always kind of like
wakes up in the morning like
sometimes you guys are gonna laugh but
sometimes i'll actually like write down
on the page like yes you stopped the
stream yes you put it up on instagram
yes you
just so like the next morning like i'm
not freaking out like oh my god did i
even turn the stream off
was it just like streaming the bottom of
my laptop like all night i don't really
know
but um yeah it's i had a good time on
the show last night was it
you know because it was a it was like it
had a true crime topic
type of thing like because it's stabbing
but at least that little girl didn't die
so i was just kind of like it wasn't
that much of a bummer
um i will say that next saturday show is
going to be a real big bummer so uh be
prepared for that
yeah they're talking about all the damn
stereotypes
that you know texas is one just just one
big cattle ranch
right and everybody's just walking
around they're still driving cattle and
spurs yeah it's
really [ __ ] funny yeah i always
wondered too like uh
i don't know i guess nobody really has
like all that many stereotypes about
florida other than everyone's a crazy
meth head but that's
actually not a stereotype that's pretty
true but
to a large extent well there's a lot of
stereotypes about the deep south that's
nothing but shacks
shacks and [ __ ] confederate flags and
guys sitting outside the porch spitting
and whittling yeah yeah
a little workout yeah
yeah when actually the only place that
it still exists to be up in appalachia
yeah and maybe not even that nowadays
i'm just like i don't know that inbred
family was like that
that's right just how long ago was that
recent
okay just go on youtube and just go for
the inbred family up in appalachia
they'll
visit them they got one of them's
barking like a dog they buried the other
one one of them died and they just
buried him in the front yard and [ __ ]
it's like a bizarre
yeah that's like something out of hills
have eyes that's crazy yeah they were
like inbred by several generations
little bitty heads yeah yeah [ __ ]
weird little bitty heads little bitty
heads yeah you see what i'm talking
about
yeah i know i know what you're talking
about but i've seen it drooling sitting
there standing there drooling
[Music]
your wards of the state state shows that
takes care of them you know
yeah they live on the porch yeah
basically they don't live in the house
evidently
well maybe they don't have air
conditioning yeah there's no air
probably there's no windows
well yeah so it's like might as well be
inside outside just outside
it's all outside but yeah so oh um i
wanted to say too i was going back to
talking about cobra kai um there's also
the whole thing with
uh john crease and they go actually a
lot into his backstory like how he ended
up being such a dick
you know what i mean so it's like so
that's kind of cool they go back to like
vietnam and all this other kind of stuff
and show how that happens um and like i
said a lot of people from the movies
make uh appearances and
i don't know it's just really oh i will
say one of my favorite things like i
said the johnny lawrence character
is easily my favorite thing it's like
every time he's on it's just like
[ __ ] hilarious
um just because he's like such a doofus
but um but in it but in an endearing way
you know what i mean like he's so
[ __ ] clueless and it's
hysterical but um the
the scene where he takes miguel
to that concert oh my god that was so
[ __ ] funny
i really really liked that scene like
with it where he goes and he's like he
sneaks this kid in with like the beers
i remember that should we say who the
concert is yeah go ahead
d snyder from twisted sister which man
as old as that dude is man he looks
he's in good shape yeah he's got to be
able to 60. how old are you got to be at
least 60.
he's got to have 10 years on me easily
yeah yeah
he looks almost exactly the same i mean
it probably helps
that he was kind of like i don't want to
say
ugly he's a weird looking dude but he's
yeah he's like he's
he's a weird-looking dude yeah so he
kind of looked like a weirdo like in the
80s
so he hasn't really changed that much
other than like not having all that
makeup on and [ __ ] yeah
um so what he would [ __ ] decent
or something else man i like listening
to to i like listening to the interviews
at d snyder
i don't want to say he's like the steven
seagal of heavy metal
but kinda in a way victor says he's 65
years old he's 65 yeah
he looks great he does look good for 65.
very good yeah
um the uh he's kind of like uh
he he kind of inflates his own
importance
in terms of in the middle seat yeah
yeah he he was [ __ ] real important on
a local level
and yeah he had some hits yeah
but it was kind of a gag kind of a band
you know you're not talking about that
zeppelin right yeah it's like let's
calm down a little bit i'm not talking
about
you know [ __ ] judas priest or
anything you know
it was a [ __ ] real good local band
you would see in a club and get [ __ ]
up yeah they're essentially like a party
like a party band right yeah i would say
i'd definitely put them
above [ __ ] like white lion you know well
i would hope so
yeah i'd even put him in i'd like i'd
prefer twisted sister to docking
i thought daca was like a kind of weak
song you know what's funny every time i
hear dawkin i remember this comedian
that i saw back in the early 90s who was
like dawkin
you sucking yeah and that just i don't
know why i think of that
single time i don't even remember what
comedian that's that's character
talking to me like it lacked character i
mean
the worst bottom of the barrel is bon
jovi but at least that had [ __ ]
character it was mainstream
teen girl [ __ ] metal all i think of
when i think of bon jovi is fringe
yeah denim jackets
i knew the market yeah john bon jovi
knew the market that he was going for
and that's
he [ __ ] made a [ __ ] ton of money on
it yeah
but i still take [ __ ] twisted sister
over bon jovi
i yeah i would as well but d snyder
kind of saw twisted sister
he kind of saw twisted sister as [ __ ]
as van halen i think that's a hardcore
van halen or maybe
not not really van halen i think i think
oh there's no way to describe it
i think he kind of thought he was the
american motorhead
i think it's not what he was though
no it was it was kind of a a
gimmick band in a way yeah i kind of
feel like it was yeah i mean the thing
about
i mean nobody can be [ __ ] motorhead
come on yeah
who doesn't love nowadays that [ __ ]
would be considered nowadays twisted
sister would be
considered transphobic i think they
would say that [ __ ] was transphobic
you can't dress up as [ __ ] women and
do that that's what they're doing
i haven't heard anybody saying that but
it wasn't well i mean i know it's like
they're not around anymore if you showed
that
okay i'm just jenny doesn't like me
[ __ ] poking fun at anything
i think today they would say that she
was transphobic you're making fun of
transsexuals well nobody is like picking
on the new york dolls and they did that
[ __ ] too like back in the 70s that was a
long time ago
they'd get sensitive about that
yeah i think they would yeah well okay
but uh
yeah so like i said i don't i don't want
to go
too much into all the [ __ ] that happens
at cobra kai because
i think everybody should watch it
because it is
delightful especially if you like the
original movies
and i'm not a huge i mean you know i
love like a lot of 80s movies and i like
the karate kid movies but they weren't
like my favorite you know what i'm
saying
but the fact that they took a property
like that
and made a series about it that is
simultaneously fun and also really like
heartfelt
but in you know kind of a cheesy
over-the-top kind of way but like i said
affectionate toward it as well
i think it was kind of like a genius
move and i actually sort of can't
believe that they did that and i can't
believe like how [ __ ]
awesome the show is and like how much
fun it is to watch
so it's like you know [ __ ] kudos to
like the writing you know
team on this and like all the actors and
[ __ ] like that especially william zabka
he's like [ __ ]
he's so [ __ ] great in this [ __ ]
show and i love the way they took
the bullies from the first ones from the
movies
and basically like expanded their arc
you know what i mean and like
gives them like redemption and things
like that and it's like really really
cool like way of doing it and it's like
also really funny
mango saying that twisted sister was
like one of the best shows he ever saw
live best show ever saw it live was
[ __ ] billy idol
whiplash smile tour and the colt opened
up cult opened up that was [ __ ] great
show
yeah he said that he thought it was
better than motorhead
i i i disagree [ __ ] motorhead's
catalog is [ __ ]
awesome motorhead had bad years every
now and then
and and
lemmy could get [ __ ] up and maybe not
deliver on stage but
man [ __ ] in the in the uh mid 80s mid
to late 80s
mid 80s actually 70s [ __ ] motorhead
was great
the [ __ ] overkill album man another
perfect
day that was a good album like an iron
fist
all that [ __ ] is all they were good they
were good yeah
bomber that was a good album yeah i like
learning a lot
they had some good live albums too you
know i never saw them live
but the driving force behind [ __ ]
motorhead was lemmy
just him as a character you know yeah i
mean you can't
i mean he cannot be replaced yeah but he
stretched the imagination yeah
just and his he was a [ __ ] here's
something else man i mean
even if motorhead didn't always deliver
all
didn't always deliver you know in terms
of album wise
there were some misses there lemmy was a
[ __ ] master lyricist
a lot of people don't realize that his
lyrics were [ __ ] really good
um he would just tell the truth
if you want some [ __ ] street wisdom
just listen to the [ __ ] lambies
lemmy's lyrics
some people are talking about their best
uh best and first concerts
louie says best show i ever saw live was
not edge nails and david bowie
that would be pretty good that would be
pretty awesome i saw nine inch nails
like so many times like not even on
purpose it's just like they opened for a
bunch of different like i like night
janels but i saw them a bunch i think a
couple times and i saw him at like the
first lollapalooza
i never got to see david bowie live i
didn't either yeah
um victor said my first concert was mega
death with the misfits
damn yeah okay my first concert was echo
and the bunnymen
and the leather nun first concert i
think i saw was like
yeah i know the first was uh biloxi down
in biloxi
it was um judas priest the turbo tour
oh okay what year was that it must have
been 80 something
i don't know i think i was just barely
old enough to get in there i think it
was about 16.
yeah i was um like i said i saw echo in
the bunny men here in orlando it was at
bobcar auditorium which isn't there
anymore
and um or it's called something i don't
even know if it's still there anymore
but i was it was 87 so i was 15.
yeah i had and i couldn't even drive yet
so i had like my daddy to drop me off
it's like really [ __ ] funny um okay
so before we wrap up somebody asked it
might have been uh might have been
sandra
but she asked me a couple nights ago or
uh on the
a couple of matinees ago that we should
say what we
what were our favorite movies from the
past year
that we reviewed so i had to go through
like all the matinee shows and pick out
the ones that
made the biggest impact that i
remembered the most some of these are
from 2019
but they're from 2019 because they
either didn't come to vod until 2020 or
i didn't see them until 2020 so
don't be too picky about it what's your
list but i wrote down okay so these are
not in any particular order these are
just like the first ones that i thought
of
and i don't even know how many it is
it's more than ten probably
um the invisible man with elizabeth moss
yeah i thought it was okay i really
liked that movie um underwater
yeah which that it's weird because
that's
i've been watching like other people's
lists like to kind of jog my memory and
that movie is like turning up on a lot
of people's like favorite
bombed at the box office but a lot of
people liked it i saw the [ __ ] [ __ ]
lie i should
saw the [ __ ] in the theater twice i
loved it i thought it was like
very close to like alien yeah it was
great right
and i think it was like surprising
because i don't think anybody was like
really expecting anything out of it but
then it like it turned out to be really
good yeah and people were [ __ ] talking
it at the time i was like i don't know
what you're talking about that [ __ ]
movie is awesome i want to get that on
blu-ray
i thought it was actually the movie i
did too yeah and like i said you're not
the only one because a lot of other
movie reviewers i saw like put it on
their
top list as well um probably will never
get a never get uh
um a uh sequel
probably not main character died in it
anyway
spoiler alert yeah so it's not like
she's gonna come back like ripley that's
true
never
and you know okay yeah all right uh
let's see what else mortuary collection
i think that one that was that anthology
with uh
with uh clancy brown in it like at the
um
that what you call it the mortuary you
know yeah yeah with all the stories i
like
that a lot i think that was technically
2019 but i didn't see it until 2020.
uh color out of space yeah good good one
good um vivarium even though that was
technically very good 2019 also but we
didn't see it until 2020.
yeah um possessor which we just saw the
brandon kronenberg that was really good
uh the platform from netflix
uh the one about the platform with all
the food on it that was going up and
down at spain yeah yeah yeah that was a
really good one i like that a lot real
good yeah
um the pool that thai movie about the
guy trapped in the pool yeah which is
crazy like i thought it was like
it was like nothing but it was like so
so good it was like i was like
biting my nails like the whole [ __ ]
time it just like got worse and worse
with the [ __ ] alligator and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
um and then some other ones alone that
uh thriller that we just saw not too
long ago i really liked that
uh mope yeah which i'm technically that
was 2019 also but we didn't see it until
this
year um also the call that uh asian one
that we saw just the other day i really
liked that a lot
which one was that and that was the one
with the girl that was talking to the
other girl like in the past
oh you know what i mean yeah really my
thing um and in pedigore which i think
was also
thai maybe i could talk about heart of
self defense wasn't it this year uh i
think that was
2018. because i wrote down i remember
you remember that korean
movie that was like set like way back in
the 1500s or whatever
zombies called monstrum yeah and i was
like i remember really loving that one
and i was like oh [ __ ] cool but then
when i looked it up i was like oh that
was 2018. was that like that long ago
that that movie came out
maybe maybe we saw it later but i was
like well i'll throw that one on there
too even though it came out two years
ago yeah
i think you're missing some maybe but
like i said i looked
i looked through the list on matinee and
those were the ones that i remembered
the best that i liked
no that was 2018 too i think
yeah color out of space they also talk
[ __ ] about it they said it sucked i
didn't think it sucked
this thought was pretty cool yeah i
thought it was cool too
yeah it was it was easily one of my
favorite movies of the year i have to
watch it again i want to watch it again
but like
i really really liked it um but yeah so
those are my ones that i picked
can you think of any that that's pretty
close yeah
because like i said i think i don't know
man
it's hard i don't know if i could pick
like a
you pretty much called him yeah i think
i got all the good ones right
i forgot underwater though yeah well
that we saw that like
wait like a year that was a year ago it
was where we saw that back in january
in january because we saw that in the
theater like a couple of times i want to
see that again i want to get that [ __ ]
on blu-ray get that [ __ ] i'm gonna get
that [ __ ] on blu-ray oracle said uh hey
jenny have you had a chance to see the
vast of night yet
no but i think we are going to watch it
tonight and review it tomorrow because i
just noticed it was on amazon prime
and um many many many people have
recommended it to me
and it looks pretty cool and like i said
it keep it kept coming up on people's
like best of the year lists
so i'm like okay i'm finally going to
like bite the bullet and watch it
tonight i think
so we'll probably review that one
tomorrow if it's on amazon prime i'm
pretty sure it is
um so we can watch that one later so it
never came out what the james bond never
came out this year
yeah they keep pushing it back yeah that
[ __ ] is never going to come out
somebody um
that's going to put them under because
that was designed to be released in the
era of theaters
it's never going to make its money back
they might as well bite the bullet
i don't want to see this [ __ ] i don't
even want to see it
um that i i sent him a trailer the other
day for the coming to america
yeah sequel which look actually it looks
like it's going to be cool
what about what about [ __ ] rudy ray
moore
is my name wasn't that this year oh yeah
that's right yeah
eddie murphy well mate was that 2019 or
2020. no i can't remember
120. it's hard to say you know what else
um
came you know what else came out was
peninsula the train to busan
yeah it was okay yeah i don't think it
was one of my favorites of the year
sadly because i was like really looking
forward to it it wasn't nearly as good
as trying to go
on um let's see victor says have y'all
seen the dark and the wicked yet no i
have not but i'm going to write that
down right now
um let's see
straw dog says i heard hunter hunter is
really good too yeah chris stuckman put
that on
uh his list too i think it was a like a
honorable mention like on his list
there's a little uh that that title
reminds me of a movie called hunter pray
it's from it's from a long time back
what was that 2009 2000 something like
but
it's it's a little bit little bitty
independent film
that's super well done it was really
good like surprise i guess
it's it's an unofficial sequel to uh
an old movie from the 80s called enemy
mine yeah by the guy gets tr
crashed on a damn alien planet with the
drag yeah yeah and the tracker mentioned
in this but
if you guys have never seen hunter pray
see that [ __ ]
really good it's only got three three
four people in the whole movie
and it's yeah it's like low budget done
real low budget has done
super well by guys that were in the
special effects industry and they just
said [ __ ] it we're going to make this
movie we are making them
they went out to the desert and made
this damn movie and uh
really good and fourth drawer down said
uh i enjoyed kingdom although it's a
series not a movie yeah that was
actually really good we saw that as well
it's kind of like a similar thing to
monstrum which was the movie but you
know what i mean it's not exactly the
same but it was kind of like a similar
setup um victor says jenny write down
take shelter also it was really good
okay so i'm writing that down
you know what i have this huge [ __ ]
list of movies another good one that we
saw this year but it's not from
2020 was [ __ ] turbo kid turbo kid was
[ __ ] awesome
that's right i really like that one when
is that from this year
i think that was actually from like 2019
or 2018 but
it took forever for it to get released
on time that's the thing it's really
cool
because a couple of these like i said
like mope and vivarium and stuff like
that they were technically from 2019 but
we didn't see them
until this year because it took that
long for them to get to beauty
turbo kid is an 80s style
post-apocalyptic superhero movie
imagine if [ __ ] there was a superhero
movie
set in the world of like cherry 2000 and
[ __ ] mad max yeah
it's kind of like that but the tone is a
little bit more like cherry 2000
and it knows it is yeah and there's a
bunch of crazy 80s stuff
it's almost kind of like something out
of fallout with the video game fallout
so
it's called turbo kid yeah [ __ ] yeah
a kid in a post-apocalyptic wasteland
becomes a [ __ ] superhero
yeah yeah teela just showed up and her
list for 2020 is
the mortuary collection black box which
i haven't seen the invisible man
host possessor his house which that's
another one i need to watch that's on my
list that's on netflix
uh gretel and hansel relic that was also
very good i forgot to mention that one
blood quantum and the vast of night so
that's
fast of night is there's another vote
for that one so like i said we'll
probably watch that tonight and review
it tomorrow
blood machines too those little mini
series was that 2020
see i thought about putting that on
there too because i was kind of like
i can't remember what year that came out
either i mean it's recent right yeah
it's got to be like oh
that vampire movie what's it called
blood vessel
oh yeah blood vessel was good that was i
think that was 2019 also but like
shutter just added it yeah
i really really liked that that i that
was like way better than i was expecting
yeah yeah like the nazi ship with all
the vampires on it yeah
that was like super cool yeah i forgot
about that one too holy crap i did
forget a whole bunch of them
god damn it
[Laughter]
so uh that that yeah that ought to be
about that
all right i gotta get out barbecue and i
got i'm making uh tandoori chicken
yeah i know i'm starving yeah all i all
i've eaten all day is
two hard-boiled eggs yeah and a cup of
coffee so my stomach is growling
[Laughter]
all right so we'll be back tomorrow like
i said probably watch the vast of night
tonight so we'll review that on the
matinee tomorrow
so as always thank you for dropping by
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow